Narrator: This is one of the
biggest stunts in "Fast 9,"
the latest "Fast & Furious" movie.
It's a four-second shot
they could have made entirely out of CGI,
but instead, they spent eight months
planning the stunt with real vehicles.
The "Fast" crew broke down
the shot into two parts
and built this track to carry
the car through the window
and into the back of this truck.
Then they programmed two
motion-controlled cameras
to perfectly sync,
and then stitched it all
into one continuous shot.
This was just one of many
over-the-top stunts in "F9,"
which were all done with
as little CGI as possible.
Justin Lin: We see cars every day.
So anytime you go to kind of a CG option,
if you're just off by a tiny bit,
the brain knows it's not real.
Narrator: And spoilers ahead for "F9."
Car flips are a common stunt
in the "Fast" franchise,
but for "F9," the production team needed
to take this move a step further
when Letty uses a magnetized
car to latch onto an SUV
during the film's climactic
chase in Tbilisi, Georgia.
Yeah, that's right.
That's a car that attaches to another car
and then flips, without CGI.
To get this to work,
the team had to reconfigure Letty's car
so it could tow the second vehicle
and then release it at the right moment.
First, stunt coordinator
Andy Gill and his team
removed the trunk.
Then they replaced it with a steel cage
so the SUV's wheel would lock into place.
To make it look like the SUV
is being sucked into
the trunk by a magnet,
the crew built a ramp behind Letty's car
so the SUV could easily hop onto it.
A weighted overhead cable system
then helped with the final backflip.
When the SUV hit the end of the line,
the cables yanked it backwards.
Now that the crew could attach and flip
one car from a moving
vehicle, how about two?
That's what happens
when Dom pulls two SUVs
to his magnetized car
before repelling them.
One SUV survives its jump.
The other SUV leaps in the air
thanks to a hidden ramp
built by the stunt team.
And that SUV is destroyed
when it hits this small car
followed by this parked van.
Andy Gill: And then
that car was pinned down
on a big steel plate in the ground,
so it wasn't going to move.
Narrator: To stop the SUV's momentum,
the van also needed a wall inside.
Gill: I just had effects
build a steel wall.
If here's your car,
right here is the firewall
all the way up to the roof,
and it put kickers back so
you can't get through it.
Then it blows through that second car
and gets halfway through
and hits that steel plate.
And that's what turns it over.
Narrator: Cables just weren't
enough for this stunt,
when a car is flipped over on its side.
While this elaborate flip
could have been completely CG,
Gill found a way to do it practically.
The key for this scene was
something called a flipper.
Basically, the car's placed on a giant pad
with two hydraulic arms that extend
and cause the pad to flip up,
launching the car along with it.
And that henchman you see here
didn't actually get hit by this car.
To flip the car without hurting anyone,
they shot the scene twice.
The first shot had the
performer standing on the car,
but there was no flip.
In the second, they flipped
the car from the same position,
but with no actor.
These two shots were then merged together
in postproduction.
Magnet-charged stunts didn't
just involve other cars.
For this moment, it was all
about kitchen appliances.
Unlike the flipper move,
it was possible to have
extras in this shot,
but that added another risk factor.
Gill: Yeah, you don't want
to be in front of one,
I can tell you that. [chuckles]
Narrator: Before placing any extras,
Gill used sandbags to see
how safe each mark was.
And location was everything.
We put a lot of time and effort
into picking the right store for that.
Had big windows, the
sidewalk was just right,
we didn't have trees or
telephone poles in the way
for them to come out.
Narrator: Launching the appliances
involved first welding
a tube into each one.
That tube was then
inserted into another tube
filled with compressed air.
Once that air was released,
the appliance would shoot
out like a cannonball.
Gill: So, as the car's coming up,
I would say, "Three, two, one, now,"
and we'd videotape it all,
and I'd put white marks on the ground
so I'd know exactly when I
said "one" where the car was
and then where those
machines were coming out.
By doing all the tests,
we knew that there was a big
brick wall between windows.
It was going to be tight,
it was going to be a
lot of stuff coming out,
broken glass and all that.
But they could hunker down,
and people in the shot just looks good.
Narrator: Dodging
washing machines is hard,
but what about explosives?
During the first big chase of "F9,"
Dom and his brother, Jake,
try to outpace each other
on jungle roads filled with land mines.
Filming on location with real explosives
meant dealing with unpredictable weather
and smoke-induced visibility issues.
Instead of using the
overgrown muddy jungle roads
on location in Thailand,
the crew built their own roads
out of decomposed granite,
a much more suitable material for racing.
In the end, they only created
about a half mile of new roads,
but the camera crew, using helicopters,
drones, and off-road buggies,
could make it feel much bigger on camera.
Gill: So it's short sections
that we'd use over and over,
and we would film in different directions,
so it looks different.
Narrator: The crew had to consider
even the tiniest details
to keep the drivers safe.
To make sure fires didn't
start near any of the drivers,
the crew wet down the mulch
that flew up in the air with each boom,
and they welded steel plates
under the driver and
passenger sides of each car
to provide an extra layer of protection
between the passengers and
any of the 30 real mortars
planted in the road.
The stunt drivers also
limited their speeds
to below 50 miles per hour,
even though in the movie
they're supposed to be going at least 80.
Gill: A lot of times,
we're not going as fast as
you would think in a chase,
but it looks a lot faster
'cause we're usually in confined areas.
Where you really want to speed it up
is when you have big, wide-open areas
and there's not really anything
relative to your speed.
So you could be doing 120,
and it doesn't look fast.
Narrator: To ensure that
the main cars looked fast,
other cars had to slow down.
Gill: We'll do wipes with cars
that are only going 10 miles an hour,
so you're going by them really fast.
Narrator: And the climax of this sequence
is even more extreme.
This is a moment when Dom and Letty
jump from one cliff to another,
attached to land by just one rope.
Even for a "Fast" movie, this was risky.
But the crew managed to
create the scene practically
with just a little help from CGI.
They filmed in a quarry with
a 60- to 70-foot drop-off
to imitate the cliff's edge.
On that edge, they reconstructed the end
of the rickety wooden bridge
as well as a steep ramp.
So the car really did jump.
Gill: We could jump, hit that post,
and then land still on the road.
Narrator: Careful camera
placement obscuring the quarry
made it look much higher on screen.
The swing was CGI, but the
swing and eventual landing
still needed to try to
follow the rules of physics.
So Gill first conducted a toy-car test
for the swing and landing,
like he did with many stunts in the film.
Here, he tied one to a string
and ran it over a table.
Gill: The toy car came off like that.
It fell really nicely for a while.
And as soon as that caught, what happened,
instead of just swinging like this,
it snapped it around almost
upside down this way,
and then back and around.
Narrator: For the landing,
they used a real car
rigged to complex cables
strategically placed on the
hood and around the back wheels.
As the car got closer to its mark,
another cable attached to the nose
stopped the front of the
car from going any further.
The forward momentum then
swung the back around,
hitting its mark perfectly.
All of these stunts were extreme,
but nothing compared
to the extensive chase
involving what may be the franchise's
most ambitious custom build yet.
This is the Armadillo,
a 14-foot-high, 26-ton,
three-section armored monster.
This beast of a vehicle had
to navigate narrow streets
while doing everything
from driving on its back
to sliding down a huge cliff.
Between this and all the magnet stunts,
it's no wonder the entire Tbilisi chase
took nearly a year to bring to life.
Four of those months were
dedicated to custom-building
two versions of the Armadillo,
one for driving it like a normal truck,
another for making it drivable
when it's turned upside down.
Those trucks are really,
really heavy, as we found out.
Narrator: Instead of building new roads,
they worked with what was already there,
first by carefully
selecting the run-up area.
These are the portions of road
where the cars in a
sequence can gather speed
before getting to the piece
of road they're filming on.
Because it was so massive,
the Armadillo needed a lot
of room to get up to speed,
and it also needed a run-out area,
or extra road after the shot ends
so nobody has to slam their
brakes and kill the momentum.
Even though the Armadillo was fast enough,
Gill found that getting
right up close to it
could make it look even faster.
Because the Armadillo
is so heavily armored,
the crew used all the tools they had
in new and imaginative ways.
For example, they could make
a dent thanks to the flipper,
which was just off camera
launching cars over here.
And the parked cars
seen at these two angles
were attached to cables on the ground
that, when cut loose,
could be pulled right
into the Armadillo's path.
Because so many parts of
these impressive feats
were done in-camera, every little detail
needed to be laid out far in advance.
But it's the experimentation
and commitment to practical effects
that make every flip and
crash feel so visceral.
That's what has always
set this franchise apart
from its humble beginnings.
Crew: Good job, man. Nice job.
I think that when you
do things practically,
when two elements interact,
it almost defies physics
because you can't
mathematically predict it
because there's so many variables.
And there's something
very visceral about that
that we connect to.
I have my toy cars all the time,
and Justin's eyes light up
every time I walk in with them
because he knows we're going to play.